I guess I want to bring things back to
Trigon because that was I I just
finished watching that like two uh no
like three weeks ago I finished watching
it yesterday
I was fresh in my mind oh it was it was
insane uh you mentioned uh that the
author had a big hand in um in the
production of this is that normal for
like anime adaptations
normally I mean normally the author is
focused on drawing their manga right so
um people involved everyone involved
want to have that author do keep on
doing that yeah yeah so they might just
review
um certain key points of the production
right and even in Dragonstone beat
actually um NATO didn't review every
single uh details right but he reviewed
the the core part that really mattered
right right what is that core part so to
drink and party hard to understand each
other as much as possible at the start
of starting before even before starting
anything
eating together yeah so basically
talking about what movies do you like
what kind of designs do you like oh wow
the whole entire questions who are you
yeah and what did you mean to design
this was the entire question of having
them so kind of getting into the psyche
of the author right yeah yeah okay
that's a that's a pretty cool method
actually rather than like doing a boring
business meeting of being like all right
so uh can you check uh to make sure that
uh vash's character design and
everything and the things he says is
cool then rather than just being like
beer yeah that character likes beer as
well you know when I was drunk as [__]
and I was writing this character this is
how I felt yeah I think I think that's a
great way of doing it because it's like
obviously you want to be able to get
into the head of the original Creator as
much as possible to make sure that you
don't have to keep like going back and
forth with them right to be like is this
correct is this correct so I mean like
how long is that process usually like
when when the the ball gets rolling it's
like okay we're doing new Trigon uh we
you know we want to make sure it's to
the likeness of the the what the author
envisioned so like how long is that I
guess just like incubation process of
making sure that everyone's on the same
wavelength ah yeah try going actually
took five years too holy [__] five years
okay I was expecting like a couple of
months or
our first year was definitely the
Intensive part right yeah I'm talking
Knight to um what what how do we
understand you drinking yeah
one one year of drinks before we're
happy to proceed I mean it's not all
drinks yeah yes just hanging out and
chatting yeah but yeah from there it
started um then how do we create this
world so naito's world is in the manga
frame itself we can't ask him to just
draw the entire what's not in the manga
yeah so because he's working on get guy
sensing I mean that's precious to him as
well yeah right right so then how can we
make something precious as equivalent or
try to at least match the preciousness
of what he created okay so we hired uh
uh actual sci-fi author to write down
the entire history for 150 years of
history from this this before the crash
to the rest of the crash oh wow so you
you just have the entire a timeline of
the world just laid out oh wow okay and
like from there you kind of like built
up from that like one timeline so from
there um we decided what to keep when
not to keep what can we describe what
can we not describe okay yeah how much
of this timeline was not in the show I'm
curious in terms of like percentage
percentage is difficult but I mean was
it like the majority there's a lot of
hundreds of pages before the crash so a
lot of it that's not included there I
don't know what the crash is should I
know what that is so in 98 Dragon it's
been so long since I watched okay yeah
yeah
um so it is okay how do you how do we
explain without spoiling okay yeah okay
okay I've already seen the original
Trigon yeah well it was in the original
Trigon anime yeah I I forgot it's been
so long so in the original trigand even
though it's kind of like a western yeah
it's obviously not set on Earth yeah
right and so Humanity has found a way
there yeah uh and basically it turns
into kind of like a Sci-Fi yeah I
remember that aspects aliens and I don't
remember why
because I feel it's not until like the
last like four or five episodes yeah I
was like what I was like okay but cool
cross go
and then bashco Super Saiyan yeah
because because I feel like a lot of the
Sci-Fi aspects in the original Trigun
that was almost not like one of the core
aspects of the show it definitely came
in like halfway through but I feel like
Trigon Stampede the first big difference
I noticed was you're like from episode
one this is a Sci-Fi show we are leaning
into that right now
um was it was it part of the creative
decision to kind of like focus more on
the Sci-Fi aspects and focus on like the
World building yeah the director
um one of his Specialties is his
question in designing everything is
where are you from where are you going
right so in Trigon they had to know
where these characters are coming from
and what their objectives and where
they're going to the end oh okay so so
going back to the timeline how much
how much didn't or how much didn't you
put in the show how much did you
actually show out of everything that you
all this work that you did before in
terms of building this world well my
partner says that we could make like
five more shows
I feel I feel like you could release
that sci-fi book as like a like an
episode zero yeah you know like a light
novel or some kind I feel this because
like you could definitely feel you know
they were definitely in in the way that
the story was structured out when you
get to know more about the crash and the
history behind the crash there's
definitely a lot of Vital Information
there that is important to the present
day of whatever episode you're watching
which you know obviously is great
because it gets him way more invested
into the storytelling but there were
also a lot of details where I'm like
okay but I kind of want to know a little
bit more about this because that would
just get me even further invested but
obviously there's a 12 episode time
limit right so you you can't [__] go
all out with it like you know the Dune
movie did the exact same thing where
it's like I'll give you a little
sprinkle in some like hints of backstory
why is it always 12 or 24 episodes
that's how the TV structured process in
Japan yeah okay I was like damn there's
gonna be a cool reason
just TV contract is okay all right some
of them are good director streaming and
don't even air on TV in Japan so but
they still keep that 24 or 12. Netflix
doesn't you think about Edge Runners
that was 10 episodes I guess so yeah but
then even on Netflix a lot of the anime
do still got 12 or and then you know if
you go to like if you go to like OVA
stuff like that like fully cooly was
only six episodes castlevania's started
off as four episodes and then Eight
Episodes so I mean I feel like it's the
difference between like let's say a
Netflix original produce anime and
something that Netflix just bought out
which that's like a big chunk though to
decide in one go like what if you have
like 16 episodes where it's like ah I
guess you just trim it down to try and
find stuff I mean that's the entire
dilemma every single and yeah it's
either too quick or or way too slow yeah
so that's based on manga it could be
ideally 16 episodes but they can only
use 12 so what do they do yeah okay so
like oh [__] I have so many questions
but I guess go into the manga thing so
you have a manga you have to adapt like
like let's say Trigon or B Stars
how do you position it so that the
season ends on like a banger you know on
like what feels like a season ending and
what if what if there's no what if what
if there's no like natural Breaking
Point what's what's the creative process
around condensing everything into 12
episodes
so um in case of B Stars didn't even try
to numb what we do is same we actually
take everything apart first right and we
look at what what is the tempo of the
film what is the tempo of the story and
what's the um how can we keep everything
but still not I'm some part we had to
cut it all up right right so basically
everything is kind of like you
everything has to be planned around like
kind of like a self-contained story arc
is what I'm what I'm getting all right
so you know going back to Trigon you
have your you have your timeline what
what comes next after the timeline so
timeline as we're developing timeline
we're developing concept Arts so then it
comes into what ideas can emerge from
the storyline visually okay so I mean we
hired uh we were working with Tajima
Koji he's the guy behind like who
designed the new Venom in the live
action Venom okay okay and so he's an
accident he he's amazing so each day he
draws dozens of images right and he he
drew 400 images for try to present just
just concept art yeah concept though I
mean I've seen I've seen a lot of
bookstores in Japan where they just sell
straight up books filled with these
concept Arts right and it's literally
like big enough for a lot of series to
just fill an entire book right and you
know some of these images you've never
seen in the show it's just like to get a
Vibe or a feel of this is what the world
and story and characters is going to be
like yeah okay yeah so 400 um we used it
some of her promotion but most of the
design is entirely different because the
idea is what really matters there so at
this point how many years into
production are you in so this is still
the first year it's still first year has
the script in written yet no okay okay
okay
um so you have okay so you have your
concept R and then I guess you kind of
like narrow down what kind of vibe yeah
so we made the found the entire
Foundation into the year right then from
the foundation we started writing the
script okay okay okay at this point was
character design like a thing or no
design is has a purpose right right like
uh industry industrial design right
always has a purpose um was the concept
for a trailer okay so it's not that I
like the style design I don't like the
design it's why are you designed that
way it doesn't work in the world that
it's set in right so it's like
can you break down what concept art kind
of like is well what is it that is being
drawn and what kind of like thing is
being built on
so for example
um
like create um it's really just kind of
hard to describe without the concept
the feeling yeah like a feeling yeah
like I mean it what Inspire I mean it's
something definitely that concept part
does it how much can we Inspire the the
scriptwriter the director the designer
right to give more of a picture of the
world yeah I suppose to kind of flush it
out because I'm yeah I mean I I'm
[__] stupid if I don't see a picture
of something I'm like I can't imagine
that like to me that doesn't mean
anything I'm a visual learner like I'm
just straight up dumb
I don't get a picture on my what am I
what am I reading here so it sounds like
the concept art is like for more of the
better terms it's like a Vibe check
right to just be like here is the the
general overarching uh feel and Vibe of
the world and then from there you kind
of start honing into the details as you
go into like character design and all
that kind of stuff is that concept yeah
that's Concepts so in the original
Trigon anime is designed as Western yeah
so there's is Western inspired so
there's what made things made out of
wood yeah yeah but if we're taking this
sci-fi approach
um this is a desert Planet there's no
plants there's no kind of plants so if
civilization human civilization brought
in a crashed ship there's no wood used
on the ship yeah so where does this word
come would come so it doesn't come from
anywhere
never thought about that so in this new
dragon Stampede we don't have any wood
architecture unless it's a this one
origin called plants um it's not it's
not um same as plants are the trees but
right I never never thought about that
try again oh my God because when you
when you see like the towns and cities
in Trigon it just I can't explain it it
just feels like yeah that that could be
real it's sometimes you just watch a
show where the world just makes sense on
a subconscious level do you know what I
mean where sometimes you watch a show
um or play a game and you're like I
don't know why this world operates this
way yeah you can't really
you already say why it doesn't make
sense just something just feels wrong
but one thing I go from watching Trigon
Stampede is that it feels like a world
that just exists yeah like you don't
stop to question it you don't stop the
question you know it's not like every
detail would spelled out but it feels
like you your brain just accepts it on a
subconscious level and I I guess I'm
like kind of figuring out why that is
now yeah I mean we figure out we thought
about
how's the population ratio of this
crashed ship where did they focus on so
the Asian population focuses on here
other population folks here how did
these people communicate so the trade
route should be focused like that so
those are all the things we thought
about exactly how deeply did you go into
like like these little details in the
works yeah the macroeconomics I mean the
book is like the space Oh my God oh my
God yeah you're basically like
recreating a civilization from scratch
yeah that's wild I thought that probably
game creators are probably doing like
this oh yeah yeah sure yeah you play
Destiny you're like go online to
download the 19 page PDF to find out why
this rock is bullied you're like what
the [__] I don't want to do that it's
like a Lord of the Rings [__] what do
you guys explain stuff to me what the
hell
so this was all done within like the
first year uh I mean that took I mean
we're starting to go into the later
years too as well okay so everything is
going in perils right so everything is
going in parallel so at which point did
like the script die being written and
like let's say the character designs
start being like finalized yeah after
the first year we started going to
designs and the script writing right but
to finalize that we we took three years
so
oh [__] okay is it is in your experience
is this like normal for an anime
production okay I mean orange itself um
is uh uncommon for a anime production we
take three years right where industry
standards like two yeah yeah yeah that's
what I thought isn't that crazy to think
like you say three years very casually
but that's the time that trash taste has
been around
isn't that wild to think about you guys
have a trusty Sammy if we started
working on episode one it would be done
right about now that's crazy oh my God
yeah it's it's interesting that you had
so much concept art done because I kind
of just assumed that because there was
like pre-existing material like manga
like like a manga there that there
wouldn't be there wouldn't need to be
this much work to be done in
pre-production I mean there's also a
previous anime as well previous anime as
well but I guess I guess this is like
the work that you don't really think
about or you don't really see